Hey team it’s Charlie and since I already
posted a non-spoilery review of Gotham this
is going to be a top 10 video that will be
a lot more specific.
I saw on twitter that most of you guys were
divided.
In terms of quality I’ll just say that the
pilot and the regular series usually look
very different.
And when you consider a show like Agents of
SHIELD.
Sometimes it can take a half a season for
it to find it’s legs.
So if you had any issues with the premiere,
just stay with it.
Fox already ordered 16 episodes, that’s
what season 1 will be 16 episodes.
They’ve only shot some of those, so they
will be able to address feedback.
I wish I’d said all that at the beginning
of SHIELD season 1 last year.
But Gotham top 10 moments from the premiere.
I should call this top 10 Batman easter eggs.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go
Number 10 - Selina Kyle’s introduction
This really reminded me of the beginning of
Tim Burton’s Batman, with the way it opened
with the mugging.
It was michael keaton on the rooftop that
time but essentially it opens with a crime
being committed.
And I like that they’re tying her to the
scene of the Wayne Murder.
There are so many different batman titles
in the comics, I can’t remember if there
was ever a version of the origin story where
Selina Kyle was present at their murder, so
I’ll say this is something new to the show.
It’s just a way to bind their characters
across time and space.
I’ll bet that both Selina’s story and
Bruce’s story will be good mirrors of each
other.
We’ll actually be able to test that theory
next week as Episode 2 will focus mostly on
her character.
Number 9 - The Murder of course
This scene has been done in every single version
of every batman story since the dawn of time.
The thing that’s different each time is
what people use it for in the story.
In Gotham, the murder is going to be the macguffin
of season 1.
Or finding the identity of the murderer.
Because apparently even the most powerful
mob boss in the city has no idea who ordered
the hit.
In case you missed it, Falcone is the boss
of bosses in Gotham, you could call him the
big bad but he’s morally gray.
Not a straight up psychopath.
Jada Pinkett Smith’s character is also a
mob boss, but answers to him.
None of them seem to have a clue who ordered
the Wayne’s murder.
It’s a little too soon to guess which villain
did it but with the way things come full circle
in most big murder mysteries, I’m guessing
Bullock or Barbara Kean’s father or someone
close to Gordon had something to do with it.
I’ll talk more about the mystery as we get
on through several episodes and learn more.
Number 8 - Bullock with the Paper
This is also a callback to Burton’s first
Batman movie when Vicki Vale is talking to
Alexander Knox and he makes the comment about
giant flying bats and the crime wave of the
century.
As dark as Bullock got in the episode, I like
to think that Donal Logue got a good laugh
when he was doing this.
His Bullock isn’t quite as angry as the
older version we see in the Animated Series.
I’m interested to learn more about how he’s
connected to the big players in the city.
I’d guess he’s directly on Falcone’s
payroll but isn’t out to hurt people.
He’s not an evil character.
Hopefully what we’ll see is some episodes
told from Bullock’s perspective this season
that explain how he got to where he is.
Number 7 - Meet the Penguin
He’s one of the first batman villains we
see and I believe he’s supposed to be in
his early twenties.
Like 10 years older than bruce wayne.
This whole episode was mostly dedicated to
him despite them cramming in so many other
characters.
His mother is going to be played by Carol
Kane, this is an actual image of her.
You would probably turn into a supervillain
too if you grew up in a home like that.
She has this amazing Grey Gardens look about
her.
I liked that later, even when Oswald was staring
murder in the face, he got really pissed when
Mooney called him Penguin.
He even limped penguin style when he was on
the pier with Gordon.
Yes he was told to never come back, but of
course he’s coming back.
I’m looking forward to more Gordon Penguin
scenes.
He spared his life so I’m interested to
see how Oswald returns the favor.
The Penguin in the canon has had periods when
he tried to go legit.
He’s one of those batman villains like the
Riddler, they don’t want to hurt people
or cause chaos just for the sake of chaos.
They just want to build something of their
own.
The reason they’re called batman villains
is because of what they do to get there, and
when push comes to shove they start endangering
people's lives.
Number 6 - Enter the Riddler
Edward Nygma is working in the police department
so we’ll get a lot more of him soon.
In the canon as the riddler he’s worked
with the police before.
He’s helped them solve cases in exchange
for money and public service he’s been ordered
to serve from past crimes.
Here on the show as far as we know that’s
all ahead of him.
I’m interested to see if he’s already
committing crimes or if we’ll get to see
him have a mental breakdown and just start
going nuts on the city.
It seems like it would be too fun for them
to not tell that story.
And since Gotham looks like it’s inspired
by the Tim Burton Batman, I’m wondering
if we’ll get a Michelle Pfiefer Catwoman
transformation scene.
When you go back and re-watch scenes like
that you have to admire the attention to style
and TV is a place where they can have more
fun like that.
Plus the Riddler has always been one of the
wackier batman villains, so I think a big
Nygma goes crazy scene would totally work
with the character.
Number 5 - Meet Poison Ivy who lives at fourth
and Grundy
This is really like two things, so I’ll
do Grundy first.
Arrow did Solomon Grundy in season 2 with
the whole Mirakuru army of blood storyline,
he didn’t die.
Because Grundy can’t die, but on Gotham
it’s just an easter egg.
Arrow does the same thing with street names
and signs.
I don’t think Gotham will bring Grundy on
the show.
Ivy Pepper is a bit of a mystery on the show
right now.
Since she’s such a small character at this
point I don’t think we’ll see much from
her right away.
They might tie her to Selina Kyle’s character
in the way Harley Quinzel and Poison Ivy spent
a lot of time together in the comics and the
animated series.
Since Gotham is just doing origin stories
I don’t expect to see any crazy Poison Ivy
powers but hopefully they’ll let her have
some fun with Catwoman.
Number 4 - Meet Barbara Kean fiancee of Gordon
and Former Lover of Montoya
In the canon her character is always talked
about in past tense.
She and Gordon are usually divorced by the
time he becomes commissioner gordon.
Montoya talked about her past which was of
course a reference to their previous relationship.
Montoya is a lesbian character in the canon.
She also becomes The Question, so I felt like
when she was talking to Barbara she was also
referring to some non-sexual extra curricular
activities.
I wondered for a brief minute if they were
going to turn Barbara Kean into Kathy Kane,
the Batwoman character from the comics.
She was also a wealthy heiress just like Barbara
Kean is on the show and she’s a lesbian.
I just felt like for a minute the show wanted
us to make that association with batwoman
in the comics and this person on the show,
even if they’re not going in that direction.
The show has cast Betty Kane, the original
Bat Girl in the comics.
That’s going to be Sarah Paxton.
No word on which episode she’ll appear in.
But I think it’s more likely they’ll do
batgirl than batwoman.
Or they could do both.
I totally dig the idea that all the vigilantes
in the city are hardcore females.
Number 3 - Meet Carmine Falcone, Gotham’s
Boss of Bosses
This character also appeared in Batman Begins.
He was played by Tom Wilkinson.
In the canon he was created to be like a Michael
Corleone figure from the Godfather.
His father was also a mob boss, Thomas Wayne
saved his life and as a result Carmine told
Bruce that he could always ask him a favor
if he needed it.
They followed up on this during Batman Year
One.
But here’s where it gets really interesting.
In the comics Falcone is Selina Kyle’s father.
It’s unclear if the show is going to deal
with this but I think it would be an interesting
way to create more bonds between all the characters.
Falcone on the show is slowly losing control
of the city, so we might meet some of the
contenders for the throne of Gotham soon.
Number 2 - Gotham Central and all the big
characters we haven’t seen yet
THere’s a lot of Police characters from
the comics we haven’t seen yet that I expect
to see eventually and add to that district
attorney Harvey Dent.
Two face will be on the show eventually.
They pretty much have their pick of the litter
when it comes to Gotham-centric batman characters.
With one exception.
and my Number 1 moment of course the Comedian.
No it was not the joker.
What they teased this summer was that they’re
going to have a string of comedians come through
the club, like each time we see one, it will
be a different person.
Fish Mooney auditioning comedians for her
club is going to be like the show auditioning
people for The Joker.
You could also say that naming Jada Pinkett
Smith Fish Mooney is a subtle reference to
the joker’s Laughing Fish.
That was an episode of the animated series
where the joker poisons the fish supply with
his neuro toxin.
Her character isn’t someone from the comics,
there is no Fish Mooney reference I could
find.
I’m not expecting to see a Joker character
ever on the show, but I am expecting to see
references to him.
And also, for people asking.
Since Arrow is doing Ra’s Al Ghul Gotham
will not.
None of the shows are going to do the same
people at the same time.
There’s no way DC Comics would allow that
kind of mass confusion.
But let me know what your favorite moment
was and if you spotted any comic book references
in the episode just write them in the comics.
I’ll be doing weekly Gotham videos so if
you like talking about Batman please subscribe
and join the team.
We meet every monday night.
Tomorrow is agents of shield season 2 episode
1, I’ll also be doing that every week.
In related news a new walking dead trailer
just dropped, so that will be my next video.
I’ll post that tomorrow morning.
Right now click here for my non-spoilery review.
I go into greater detail about what I thought
of the episode and click here for my agents
of SHIELD season 2 preview.
Thanks for watching, now everybody high five
and we’ll meet back up tomorrow.